wacken vertriebs ja das ist doch so
ziemlich das härteste was musik zu
bieten hat dieses
heavy-metal-festival
75.000 fans in diesem jahr eigentlich
nur 2000 seelen örtchen in schleswig
holstein heute geht das wieder los mit
headbanging und dosenbier dort in diesem
dörfchen das wacken open air das ist
zurück nach zwei jahren langen jahren
corona pause
schneller härter lauter 1990 hat es mit
800 besuchern angefangen heute ist es
das bekannteste heavy-metal-festival der
welt backen und dieses provinznest hier
wird zum metal mekka ein kleiner ort im
westen schleswig holstein hier leben
eigentlich mehr kühe als menschen aber
an drei tagen im jahr platz das
beschauliche wacken fast aus allen
nähten und alle feiern mit während
damals thomas jensen und holger hübner
nicht gewesen hätte die welt was
verpasst freunde mitte zwanzig heavy
metal fans und zu viel langeweile
außer der dorfdisco blasmusik war im
kleinen bakken absolut nix los also
organisieren die beiden jung sein
eigenes open air festival und zwar mit
erfolg eine sandkuhle ein bierzelt und
sechs bands später ist das festival
geboren für zwölf mark eintritt gab es
für die 800 eingefleischten metal-fans
harte musik viel bier und
familienatmosphäre seitdem geht es steil
bergauf schon zwei jahre später pilgern
3500 feierwütige rocker in die provinz
es drücken sich rock und metal legenden
wie motörhead slayer ozzy osbourne deep
purple oder iron maiden über die
jahrzehnte das mikro in die hand aus der
sandkuhle im nirgendwo sind bis heute
250 hektar festivalgelände geworden das
entspricht 3 150 fußballfeldern
80.000 fans aus der ganzen welt finden
ihren weg in die norddeutsche provinz
und nach zwei jahren corona pause rasten
die vollblut rocker ab heute wieder
richtig aus
schauen wir direkt dorthin dosen bier
zum frühstück bei klara marie becker
reporterin der wacken und
feiern
für mich ist es hier heute das erste mal
wacken ich war noch nie hier mir wurde
schon gesagt das ist das frühstück der
champions das habe ich mir schon mal
geholt habe mich schon darauf
eingestimmt aber ich bin hier mit
absoluten experten die mir hoffentlich
heute oder die milch noch zu backen
experte expertin machen können für euch
ihr seid extra aus stuttgart gekommen
ist es das wievielte mal wacken seit
2017 durchgehend
leider groß ist war ja leider hat uns
bewohner einiges versaut aber jetzt sind
wir wieder hier um ordentlich gas zu
geben und ihr seid schon seit gestern
jetzt schon gestern ordentlich gefeiert
was ist euer erstes fazit worauf freut
ihr euch die nächsten tage ja es gibt
viele bands die museen wollen viel wie
die geilen leute einfach
das ganze feeling endlich mal normale
leute endlich mal normalen leute endlich
mal normale leute viel bier prost auf
ein gutes wacken und ja ich hoffe dass
ich mich jetzt hier heute im laufe des
tages noch richtig ja ein bisschen auch
vielleicht noch optisch mehr einfügen
kann freu mich auf mein erstes mal
backen und freue mich auf den tag hier
mit den leuten zu das erwarten wir von
dir klarer das ist noch nicht ganz noch
nicht ganz so wie man sich da kleidet im
wacken und du hast doch noch keinen zug
genommen von dem frühstücks büchern habe
ich gerade gesehen vielleicht können wir
an grünen da einmal am tisch schon ja ja
wohl geht doch dosen bier zum frühstück
lager marie becker wohl einmal auf
wacken bisschen grün wir machen bisschen
stimmung
also
eigentlich klar möchte ich diesen langen
haare neben dir noch durch die luft
wirbeln wird glaubt nicht dass ist das
sein kann wenn man solche haare hat muss
man auch headbangen dafür ist man noch
in wacken das wird ich bin total sicher
naja ich hoffe das lerne ich heute alles
noch so klar da denke ich meinte sie ich
meinte den mann nehmen wir aber das wird
vielleicht öfter noch zu verwirrung
führen heute backen klara vielen
herzlichen dank dir live aus wacken und
hören wir mal wie die fans dort in
wacken die tausenden die sich längst aus
ganz deutschland aus der ganzen welt ja
im grunde auf dem weg gemacht haben und
dieses schleswig holsteinische dörfchen
wie die sich ja warm laufen wie die sich
angewöhnt für das was in den nächsten
tagen da passiert
jetzt schon auf der bühne
das flair das
die größe vor allen dingen also dass das
weil ich viele verschiedene sachen sehen
die man gar nicht kennt erkennt und
wände erkennt man dann viele leute
kennen ja und einfach die stimmung hoch
zwischen den leuten kommen
[Musik]
- einfach diese stimmung und mit
freunden einmal um eine woche lang
ambitionierte richtig ausrasten also
richtig ausrasten und das sind für die
bemerkung aber sind ja halt ganz normale
leute die dann richtig die sau
rauslassen in wagner und es sind
prominente die auch richtig abgehen bei
heavy metal heimliche
heavy-metal-fans kennst du welche
das war einfach keinen heimlichen als
endung ist vielleicht die top five nein
nein noch nicht aber das wird nicht
heute aber es gibt die top five der
heimlichen heavy metal fans lasst uns
mal reinschauen patricia also er hier
zum beispiel charly hübner bekannt als
polizeiruf 110
wobei man muss sein also wenn er so bei
wacken ankommen kann im land zug und
bisschen kopfnicken daher kann mehr der
lässt es richtig krachen absoluter
motorradfan hat damals das hat er mal
erzählt erst mal vorsichtig mit ac dc
angefangen und ist dann richtig
abgegangen bei der ersten motorhead
kassette und er geht auch hier bernd
alker der ist schon mehr in wacken
stimmung heim das ist mein wirkliches
haus gängen er obwohl es mit dem
headbanging so schwierig ist bei ihm ne
hollywood nämlich auch jim carrey metals
ohne bei dem hätte das irgendwie schon
eher gedacht zudem passt das ständig er
vielleicht ist auch hollywood einfach
härter als rosie coker hätte es gedacht
cameron die jetzt klar die ist ja auch
mit einem echten rocker nein ich ganz
heavy metal wird zumindest mit einem
rocker fahrrad
trockenraum 1 feiern die letzte seite
nach innen frau ziehe nach wacken kommt
nicht ganz bekannt und er ist natürlich
eine donald trump auch der headbanger im
herzen hat immer wieder gesagt metal
grey to grey also auch er mehr als ein
heimlicher heavy metal und
möglicherweise auch wacken fan und dann
gibt es noch ein hierbei bilden im haus
den kennen sie eigentlich ganz anders
schauen sie auf diesen mann rechts im
bild er treibt sich normalerweise im
weißen haus rum oder mit dem ist real
mit dem ex bundespräsidenten ja wie die
beiden links keine metal fans aber
dieser mann hier im kanzleramt ralf
schuler unser
parlamentskorrespondent jahre lang auf
den spuren von angela merkel der kann so
dreht man den sound auf hier das ist bei
ihm zu hause da wird nämlich laut
körperlich den höheren reif hallo
aus sicherheitsgründen aus
sicherheitsgründen
was das ist ralf schuler normal
im job
die offizielle ralf schuler
das ist richtig krachen brille und hier
marschierte ein und
er macht überhaupt etwas für waschen
juli bei
so ist normal
er weiß ganz genau
was ist noch musik und wo fängt der lärm
an eine kleine liebeserklärung von
ehrenmord
107 dann metal was gibt's anderes warum
weniger musik bekommen wenn man das
volle brett kriegen kann voll aggro voll
drauf volle lautstärke warum leise
geschrammelt nur nur mittel ist musik
ich frage mich manchmal ob die echte
heavy-metal-fans irgendwas hören weiß
ich noch was ich mir da nicht
erschlossen hat was ich noch nicht so
höre weil ich suche man nach so was ist
drin ist drin mussten musste mir genau
die hotlines anhören da ist ein bisschen
lang die melodielinien darunter liegen
hat also auch hier bei herthas worden
was wir gerade hatten ganz subtile
melodielinien die kommissare fällt
übrigens sind schwer linksradikal alle
veganer also auch das gibt es nicht nur
dosenbier dienst nehmen auch keine
drogen aber da ist viel mehr drin also
es heißt nicht umsonst melodic death
metal aber du kannst natürlich aus trash
metal muss sehr schnell zugeht oder
speed metal hören und für mathematiker
gibt es auch spezielle formen wo die
taktzahlen so ungerade sind dass sie
beim zählen irgendwie irre wurst seit
wann tut sich dieser abgrund in deinem
leben auch besser heavy metal abgrund
seit wann und was haben deine freunde
was sagt deine familie was haben deine
eltern dazu wie sie in der familie
bekomme ich keine mehrheit dafür dass es
gibt zu mischformen man könnte
apocalyptic gehören das sind zwei sehr
sympathische leute aus finnland die auch
verstärkten cello spielen oder andere
länder zum beispiel aus kanada die haben
super akustik eingespielte album
ansonsten wenn man trommelt er will man
einfach ausgelastet sein instrument ist
nicht deswegen beginnen
und zwischendurch gehst raus holt den
kaffee dass es muss einfach gerade
vorwärts gehen wie in der politik also
entweder volles rohr oder gar nicht und
schmeißt du dich kleiner auch rein ich
bin ja immer beeindrucken wenn man nur
sieht wie alle vorne stehen und sie
fasst die köpfe einschlagen irgendwie
geht es aber immer gut aber auf jeden
fall headbangen so hatte sich völlig die
orientierung verlieren sich investition
würde aber
nicht im zentrum von morgen wie vorne
mit rumkugeln das überlasse ich den
anderen weg geht es eher um die musik
aber ist natürlich
schön wenn es richtig kracht und man
kann mit theby metal auch kleine
erdbeben simulieren das ist biologisch
messbar zum schluss noch einmal aus ralf
schuler smm und dem mund unseres
parlaments korrespondenten der mann der
so lange über angela merkel berichtet
hat der auf den spuren des
finanzministers jetzt immer unterwegs
ist für uns hier bei bild das offizielle
ralf schuler
heavy-metal-festival gegröle für wacken
motto
guck mal mit der hoch ich habe extra auf
die melodie geachtet wie es von reits
gelernt habe danke danke reif der beste
den wir je hatten der beste rat
[Musik]